when Netflix released a second trailer
the streamer shares some words from One
Piece Creator a chiro Oda in a note that
was posted to Twitter odas said that he
fully expected fans of the source
material to highlight the differences
between the manga and the live-action
show after the launch I'm sure I hear
about some people pointing out how this
character is missing or that scene is
omitted or this bit is different from
the manga but I'm sure they'll come from
a place of love so I intend to enjoy
even those comments as odar predicted
most of the early comments were
good-natured with fans on the whole
accepting that some changes need to be
made when it comes to creating something
in real life one Reddit user wrote I
definitely see some changes to the plot
our Long's Crews seemed to show up at
the baratier buggies Cruise teams of a
natural circus going on plus it seems
like the going merry encounters garp's
ship at one point everything still looks
really good though you'll never please
everyone when it comes to adopting a
beloved manga series but the live-action
one piece seems plenty of support from
the fandom when it comes to making
tweaks of course having odor on board
certainly helps